flores juguetes y cientos de cruces
desde hace más de cinco meses los
alrededores de la escuela primaria de
ubalde se han convertido en un monumento
a las vidas arrebatadas demasiado pronto
el 24 de mayo un joven de 18 años entró
en la escuela y mató a 19 niños y dos
profesores dejando a la comunidad
consternada
[Música]
y vine a presentar Mis respetos no
deberían haber muerto así me gustaría
que muchas cosas cambiaran y que la
violencia con armas se detuviera El
rifle de asalto que se utilizó en la
masacre era una r-15 fue comprado
legalmente este fue el tercer tiroteo
escolar más mortífero de la historia de
Estados Unidos y reavivó el acalorado
debates sobre el acceso a las armas
algunos residentes de uvalde asisten a
una pequeña reunión con candidatos
demócratas el gobernador de esta
localidad es republicano y se ha
asegurado de que Texas siga siendo un
estado a favor de las armas pero los
padres víctimas del tiroteo de uvalde
exigen respuestas y acciones tengo otros
cuatro hijos y tengo que protegerlos
cambiar es aumentar la edad para comprar
un arma de asalto de 18 a 21 años
aumentar los controles de antecedentes
lo que queremos es una prohibición
completa en las armas de asalto a nivel
Federal Javier Cázares también perdió a
su hija Jackie ese día después del
tiroteo decidió lanzarse como candidato
a las elecciones locales y cuando toma
la palabra hay emociones fuertes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero cuando habla con los periodistas
sus comentarios se tornan mucho más
moderados Lo principal es que no estamos
tratando de quitarle las armas a nadie
solo intentamos hacer que sea un poco
más difícil para la gente con esa
mentalidad con esa edad que les tome un
poco más de tiempo obtener un árbol
prueba una vez más que aquí en Texas y
en gran parte del país la cultura de las
armas no va a desaparecer aquí es donde
guardo las armas en mi casa
ha coleccionado rifles desde que era un
adolescente este es uno de mis calibres
favoritos
es la versión
que acabo de mostrarles
y caza en su tiempo libre también es un
firme defensor de la segunda enmienda
que garantiza el derecho a aportar armas
para él las leyes que intentan
restringir ese derecho no cambiarán nada
las armas están satanizadas por la mitad
de este país
la culpa no recae sobre ellas la culpa
recae sobre la facultades mentales de
las personas que cometen estos actos
atroces
Y estos locos no tuvieran acceso un arma
no habrían hecho nada
Por supuesto que no habrían encontrado
otra manera
hay otra razón por la que este
empresario tejano está en contra de
leyes de armas más estrictas llevaba 22
años organizando ferias de armas hoy
organiza una en una importante cadena de
hoteles de San Antonio Dentro de este
salón de baile hay más de 170 mesas que
pronto estarán cubiertas de armas de
todo tipo aquí ahora literalmente de
todo habrá pistolas habrá revólveres
habrá escopetas rifles lo que llamamos
armas largas no se nos permitió
quedarnos para el evento pero
emprendedor dice que espera ganar
bastante dinero este fin de semana de 15
a 20 mil dólares por Estas armas el año
pasado los estadounidenses compraron
casi 20 millones de armas el doble que
hace 15 años según una organización de
comercio de armas solo en Texas la
industria armamentística está valorada
en 5000 millones de dólares y Eso sin
contar el mercado negro en California el
departamento de policía de San Diego
está librando una batalla contra lo que
se conoce como armas fantasmas
hace unos meses el teniente Paul
Phillips creó la primera unidad de la
policía dedicada a las armas de fuego
caseras esto tiene un número de serie
pero está modificada tiene este
interruptor clock en la parte trasera
hace que se descarguen todas las balas
del cargador al apretar el gatillo solo
una vez algunas armas son modificadas
para hacerlas más letales otras son
construidas desde cero utilizando kits
caseros o impresoras 3D compradas en
línea si nos fijamos normalmente habría
un número de serie aquí y al lado y no
hay nada el número de armas fantasma ha
aumentado exponencialmente probablemente
el 25 o 30% de las armas de fuego son
armas fantasmas cada vez es más fácil
conseguir o ensamblar armas gracias a
los vídeos que se publican en internet
este agente cuya identidad permanecerá
oculta Explica cómo todo lo que se
necesita es un taladro brocas se
necesitan herramientas mínimas para
hacerlo como se puede ver el problema
que vimos es que Estas armas caminando
en manos de las personas que tienen
prohibido tenerlas en mis 25 años como
policía nunca había visto tantas armas
en las calles la accesibilidad y la
facilidad de conseguir Estas armas nos
han traído esto desafortunadamente en
sólo unos meses su unidad pude recuperar
unas 200 armas ilegales un éxito Sí pero
apenas es una gota de agua ante la
magnitud del problema